they are often billed as family friendly
but sometimes television shows designed
for young audiences contains some really
dark and twisted stuff with plots
involving depression abandonment and all
kinds of real-world horrors
it's amazing that some of these episodes
ever made it on the air here are some of
the worst offenders The Fairly
OddParents it's a wishful life from the
opening moments of this episode things
go downhill fast
Timmy the main character keeps trying to
do good deeds but nobody appreciates his
efforts even his loved ones
understandably upset he wishes that he'd
never been born a wish that his fairy
godparent Wanda reluctantly grants in a
parody of It's a Wonderful Life
you know the beloved Christmas movie
about offing yourself yeah so you still
think killing yourself would make
everyone feel happier right I don't know
Timmy sees what the world would be like
without him however unlike the movie
Timmy discovers that everyone he knows
is much happier if he's not around even
more troubling timmy is later shown the
hellish place where all the kids who
wish they were never born go implying
that this sort of thing happens on a
regular basis
later Jorgen von strangle explains that
the whole thing was a setup
aimed at teaching a lesson the lesson
that you can't even trust your fairy
godparents especially if you're going
through a tough time in your life Boy
Meets World cult fiction ABC's
coming-of-age sitcom Boy Meets World
didn't shy away from difficult subjects
but one episode tops them all season 4
is cult fiction thanks to his turbulent
home life Shawn frequently struggles
with loneliness and abandonment issues
and that makes him a perfect mark for a
local cult that targets troubled kids
before long he's hopelessly brainwashed
by the cults leader mr. Mac later
Shawn's teacher mr Turner who served as
a sort of surrogate father to him is
involved in a bad motorcycle wreck and
is hospitalized unable to cope with the
situation
Shawn brings mr. Mac to the hospital
with him where Cory's father and
principal Feeney have a confrontation
with the cult leader
they brought Shawn down Thanks don't
want you to just take a hike back to
Conlon
now do you see how judgmental these not
know instant meanwhile Cory and Topanga
brings Shawn to mr. Turner's room and
forced him to confront the reality of
their teachers condition head-on leading
to an emotional monologue where Shawn
talks directly to God don't pull me off
John don't blow me off god I've never
asked you for anything I never wanted to
come to you like this Rugrats Angelica's
worst nightmare if you grew up watching
Rugrats you might not have been aware of
the heavy themes but as an adult you'll
soon notice some of the really tragic
backstories that go unnoticed by the
babies the darkest episode though is
Angelica's worst nightmare Angelica
pickles enjoys her status as a spoiled
only child so what her mother announces
that she's pregnant
Angelica's fragile ego is thrown into a
tailspin her parents ignore her while
discussing the pregnancy and Angelica
begins to worry that they won't have
time for her and a nightmare Angelica's
baby brother has arrived and her parents
have forgotten who she is forcing her to
live in the laundry room and eat table
scraps
after taking everything she loves the
gigantic baby chases Angelica out of the
house before catching her and starting
to eat the car which causes her to wake
up screaming later Angelica's parents
tell her that they aren't going to have
the baby after all and while she feigns
disappointment Angelica is secretly
pleased about the sad news the Powerpuff
Girls Twisted Sister in the Powerpuff
Girls episode Twisted Sister the trio of
cute cartoon superheroes find themselves
overwhelmed with school chores in
constantly saving the day they decide to
create a fourth Powerpuff Girl to help
share the load but instead of following
the professor's original formula of
sugar spice and everything nice the
girls use artificial sweetener dirt and
things like crayons lizards and boxing
gloves along with a secret ingredient
Chemical X the result is a gigantic
misshapen and not very bright new
Powerpuff Girl that they named bunny
[Music]
unfortunately bunny mixes things up
throwing police officers in jail while
letting the criminals run free when her
sisters arrived they angrily tell bunny
that she's bad and can't be a powerpuff
girl heartbroken bunny flies away to
sabor our doubt on a lonely cliffside
but returns when her sisters are in
danger to defeat all the bad guys
excited that she's finally been good
unfortunately this effort was too much
for Bunny's unstable body and she
explodes a piece of her dress flutters
to the ground and the girl's cries they
realize how awful they were even the
narrator of the show can barely handle
it Tom and Jerry blue cat blues in stark
contrast to the typical slapstick antics
found in the classic cartoon Tom and
Jerry the 1956 feature blue cat blues
has an extremely tragic and traumatizing
plot Tom falls in love with a beautiful
white cat but although she returns his
affections at first she eventually
leaves town for a rich neighborhood cat
named butch Jerry tells Tom to move on
with his life but Tom can't let go
and eventually literally sells himself
into slavery to buy her a car cost an
arm and a lake but he willingly sold
himself into slavery for love which
promptly gets destroyed by Butch's fancy
coupe heartbroken and hopelessly in debt
Tom turns to the bottle the milk bottle
that is and decides to sit down on the
train tracks and end it all once the two
cats get married Jerry had a loss on how
to cheer up his friend consoles himself
that at least his own girlfriend
wouldn't do that to him just then Jerry
sees his own girlfriend drive by with a
different Mouse with a just married sign
on the back of their car - realizing
that life now holds nothing for him
either
Jerry joins Tom on the track and the
screen fades to black as the sound of a
train whistle approaches the end
Thomas the Tank Engine the sad story of
Henry most episodes of the popular
children's series Thomas the Tank Engine
are rather cheerful Affairs usually with
Thomas or one of the other engines
learning a valuable lesson after being
stubborn or childish in some way in the
sad story
Henry a similar setup leads to a
decidedly dark turn the green engine
Henry is afraid the rain will ruin his
bright and shiny paint so he takes
refuge inside a tunnel and then refuses
to leave it even after the rain stops
when logical reasoning firm orders and
even brute force failed to budge the
silly steam engine railway manager and
father figure Sir Topham Hatt finally
gives up workers pulp the rail for the
tunnel and lay bricks over the entrance
trapping Henry inside the other engines
cheekily whistle at Henry as they pass
and he becomes extremely lonely and
miserable and the soot from their smoke
ruins his shiny paint as the sad green
engine contemplates his unknown fate
even the narrator ringo starr gets in on
henry's public humiliation but i think
he deserved his punishment don't you
that's right kids if you misbehave then
it's completely normal for your parents
to lock you in your room and not let you
out and if you've been really naughty
they might never come back and then a
former Beatle will say you deserved
everything you got thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this other cool stuff we know you'll
love to
[Music]